oh my God
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste time Conan and once again I'm
joined by the boys we are the boys
I had a stunning Revelation this week
okay it sounds like an AI okay
how much water one [__] takes
okay what do you mean Enlighten us okay
so uh the other night we went out uh for
Sydney's birthday I had to be back by 1
30 because uh a.m yeah because they were
shutting off all the power to uh my
apartment
um
for like three hours right so I was like
I want to get back I was like I don't
want to walk a bunch of stairs in the
elevator yeah also I don't even I don't
even know what the [__] stairs are in
my apartment I can do that they can just
shut off Powers Yeah I mean they usually
let you know like monsters in advance
but it's like right right it is what it
is and I was like oh whatever no big
deal yeah and so uh power goes out
obviously I don't even notice because
I'm fast asleep I get back by 1 30 and I
order ubereats and the guy arrives so
that was that was good that was like the
kind of hype moment I was like is it
gonna arrive for 1 30 because I don't
know I'm I'm not walking down those
floors
I'll make him walk up yeah I'd be like
bro just just eat it you can have it
um so go to sleep wake up and uh
like at eight o'clock or something this
I don't even know I had this there's
like a giant like tanoid speaker in my
apartment which the building has access
to which I didn't even know I didn't
know what this thing was because I'd
seen it on my ceiling I didn't know what
it was some announcement gets made at
like 8 A.M and I was like half asleep so
I was not paying attention by the time I
realized oh my God there's a loud
[__] voice speaking in my apartment
which is weird
uh I was like oh that's odd and then
Eugenie was staying at my house at the
time yeah I'm playing games uh with
mouse and then he goes Connor Connor I'm
like
he's like
um it's wrong with the toilet I was like
what he's like yeah so what's wrong with
the toilet I'm like oh okay I dropped a
fat donkey in it I was like he's like
yeah I'm sorry I'm like oh bareback guys
he's Mouse on stream and I was like all
right what's wrong he's like yeah it's
not flushing so I go to it and I feel
that like when I pull the toilet thing
there's no water in the tank yeah wash
it I'm like oh that's weird and I'm like
okay well I guess let me let me let me
have a think so I'm going around my
kitchen to get some water and I realized
the water wasn't coming on I'm like oh
[__] all the water's gone in the
apartment right there's nothing and then
that's what I realized that was what the
announcement was for
and so
now I couldn't flush the toilet but he'd
taken a [__] poop in my goddamn
toilet
so
now the only way I could flush the
toilet was if I had enough water to uh
put in the water tank and then flush it
now I had run a bath the morning before
and there's a giant bath of water and
Eugena took a bath and pulled the
goddamn plug out so my giant supply of
water that I could have used for things
is now gone right right because how the
[__] am I supposed to flush this poop
down the goddamn toilet but the problem
was as well is that I also was needing a
toilet as well and I was like oh my God
I don't know what to do I want to hold
it till the water comes back on and I
was like I don't know when the water's
gonna come back on and and now I started
to realize how often I needed water
because I was like oh I'll just go wash
my I can't wash my hands yeah you can't
wash my hands there's no water yeah and
then
I had I had like maybe a liter or two of
water in my fridge yeah and uh I could
have done a few things of this could
have water my plants could have washed
my hands
um but I really wanted a coffee and so I
was like Eugene man
sorry dude I'm making I'm making a
coffee with the last water we have left
I'm making a different kind of brown
Water actually I should flush the toilet
I could do some other things uh I'm
gonna make a coffee with this last one
right I would come to regret this
decision later on as I really needed a
lot of water right but as the building
kind of like realized that hey people
will need to go to the toilet still they
were offering free like bottles of water
to flush your toilet with and I was like
great so I picked up two two liter
bottles of water how long was this
maintenance going on for it was like all
day [__] yeah it's usually all day [__]
no so it was like an emergency thing it
wasn't scheduled the water wasn't
supposed to go off oh an electrical
thing yeah like I wanted to shower and
do stuff and I don't know if you if you
guys get this sometimes you don't you're
a night person morning shower people
will probably understand the pain of not
being on a morning shower because you're
like I just don't feel like my day is
starting yet I just need to shower I
feel like I can't get any work done I
can't even start the day I can't even my
brain doesn't function sounds like it
sounds like a skill issue at least even
just wash my face I don't know why I
just need some water contact with my
body yeah um I was tempted to just go
outside and start [__] spraying
myself with Febreze to have some
sensation of jumping the roof yeah like
um but I was getting to the point where
like I could not hold my [__] any longer
right and I was like this is dangerous
game they're doubling up on the poop in
the toilet right but it was I was dying
and now a smart person would have told
you kind of just go to a convenient [__]
I was refusing to be intelligent at all
and I was like well because the
elevator's out as well right yeah yeah
so I was I was kind of like all right
um I'll just I'll just take the poop
I'll just take this poop I am I I'm sure
the day you think about it later I'll
I'm sure the water will come back on
anytime now so I take a poop but
unfortunately this was a [__] massive
goddamn poop that I took and now now my
toilet bowl was very much too full
so
I I was like all right we gotta try and
flush this so I I got the two two liter
bottles of water so four liters of water
yeah I put it in the tank to because so
as you know that that thing fills up
with water and that uses that to push
yeah sorry I poured four liters in I
flushed the four leaders nothing it
didn't budge at all I was like holy [__]
how many liters of water do I need you
know there's an easier method that uses
less water right what so what you so I
learned about this from like you know
during like uh earthquakes or like
typhoons and stuff like that where the
water might just suddenly be cut off
yeah what you do is a lot of toilets the
the the thing that separates the the
bowl from the pipe yeah is this little
flap yeah and when you flush the toilet
the pressure from the water is the thing
that opens the flap yeah so what you do
is you what you should have done you
should have gotten those two things of
water filled it in with a bucket yeah
and then flush the bucket down this the
the the bowl all at once because then
that's so much more water going into to
the ball all at once and it opens the
flap I don't know I'm I'm just saying
this is like a normal thing I'm it's
it's a southeast Asia things a lot of
toilets don't have automatic flushes
there we use the bucket technique I was
like I was like everywhere what a
universal when I heard you pouring the
water into the toilet I was like I was
like no gonna wait no no not the not the
place you poop right yeah
no no no you get a bucket and you just
pour it in the place you poop and you
just oh I did that too but it was too
much how big was your [__] it was two
people's [__] and my mom was at least a
1.5 cents like it was it was it was a
big one and so now this is like what
would have been maybe like even a tough
flush on a normal day yeah it'd become
just way too big of a fly right right
and you know and so and now we're
starting to smell pretty [__] bad
yeah I mean apartment it was just kind
of like oh my God so I went down again
and I got uh [__] eight [__]
bottles of water
and uh I flushed it again and it didn't
[__] work and I was like I think you
just have a broken toilet I was like no
this is too big it was too big but it
did flush some of it so then I had to go
down again and get more and then finally
I managed to get it going and I was like
holy [__] I used like like 10 liters of
water to flush one [__] and now I'm now
every time I go to the toilet and I
flush I'm like that's a lot of water I
just wasted like I feel bad I'm like I
drink less water than I flush down the
drain every day well I mean like I'm I'm
used to not flushing every single time
because in Australia like we're in a
drought like a long time right so they
actually teach kids being like if it's
yellow let it mellow if it's brown flush
it down
you know what I'm talking about right I
don't
know he's like to uh to the only other
Australian yeah you know what I'm
talking about
but that's how I was told because it's
like you don't want to waste water
because you use as you found out yes a
shitload of water to flush the toilet
it's literally a [__] I knew it was a
lot of water but I guess just visually
having to pour that much water in to
have one [__] was like oh my God yeah
people must feel like when they find out
like first first of all people when they
find out like poverty exists like oh my
God they live like these damn [__] like
I obviously like I was familiar with how
Plumbing works but I think I think the
the Strat that you should have done is
you should have not taken the [__] on
top of the [__] no that was me that was
me being pretty gung-ho about it yeah I
was like it'll come back on any time
though and it and it didn't come on
until like 6 p.m yeah right so I was
like this [__] sucks yeah it was out
all day right
um so that was kind of shitty okay like
what's the longest you've gone without a
shower or a bath because uh one week
one week I'm sure there was a long
period that I can't remember right right
because like I I remember there would be
some points right where you know it's
you know the water was working but in
England uh we'd have a boiler and you
know if for some reason the boilers are
always spoilers if someone takes one
[__] bath and it's like all right no
one gets to have hot water yeah no no
one gets to have hot water you can wait
like two hours what a [__] sister yeah
yeah yeah so sometimes the boiler just
doesn't work and you know sometimes it
you have to wait a while to get like
Plumbing there and uh the the planets
like either replace the boiler or fix it
or something so you'd uh you know that
would be like sometimes two two like a
two-week stint where I just would not
have any hot water right like do you are
you okay showering cold shower
if I have no choice yes yeah even if
it's in England in the winter
maybe not yeah because like I
I I remember that like the boiler would
always obviously like break at always
like the worst points and uh I remember
it's at one point I just got started
getting used to it and I didn't take
cold showers but I I did feel like I had
brought like let's say the second third
world country experience to England
because what we'd have is we'd have like
we we just bought like extra like
massive pots and pans it would hit about
like 6 p.m and my dad's like does anyone
want a shower
yeah yeah I'd be like I'd be like oh
yeah I'm planning to showering about now
and my dad like brings out like the we
had like uh we we had like four like
stoves so we bring out like four massive
pots start filling up with cold water
and start like boiling our hot water for
like the evening which is what we'd use
it's gonna be so inefficient compared to
a boiler probably is very very much very
very inefficient how do people live like
that oh no man for me for me it was like
a week uh it wasn't so much like I
didn't want to take a cold shower it's
just we didn't have water to shower
because I was out in the middle of
[__] no way camping for a week yeah
so it's like the water is very scarce
because we're very far away from
civilization so it's like we're gonna
save this in Australia and it's
Australia so we're going to use this
water to drink and so I had no choice
but to just not shower for a week and
then when I got home and I had that
shower I felt like I was born again I
was like ah all my sins were just
getting washed away for not showering
for a week never again though yeah isn't
it like was it Johnny Harris that made a
video where he was like didn't shower or
didn't shampoo or shampoo okay okay
because I didn't know people in
dreadlocks like first time
because I didn't know if it was the
science where it's like better to not
shower or if it's better to not wash
your hair I think I think there's a few
things again we could be all lying yeah
chatting out of our ass but I think
they're like I think showering or at
least washing your body with a shirt
every day is unnecessary yeah because it
gets rid of like the oil yeah you know
you don't need to you don't need to
shampoo every day either no I think
shampoo they say you should maybe do
like twice a week but even then I think
it's like contentious I can't remember
yeah it depends on your skin uh like uh
yeah
all right all right guy talk guy talk
all right how far do you boys go with
grooming yourselves like in terms of
like okay okay in terms of wear okay
okay here's it okay okay question
question one question one do you shave
your chest do your chest hair I don't
have Chester
oh
three little strands of hair that is
just like there's just like three little
strands of my manly Hood just being like
yeah
I don't
my hair grows on the body and like which
is completely different random
assortments why can't we just grow like
fur like a monkey like all over like my
legs are hairy my arms are hairy and my
chest's a little hairy but like not much
else and it feels just kind of random
when my body was like listen yeah and
it's like at least the [__] monkeys
were like let's commit yeah
monkeys come here with having hair all
over they were like let's just get it
all over like why do this mismatch
[__] like I don't know uh but what
other types of groups all right armpit
hair Juju cut or shaves those shave
those no I think I I someone told me
that if you cut it you sweat less so I I
tried that because I feel like I my
armpits is in the summer here just go
[__] faucets yeah but I find that it
only helped slightly I think I think the
problem I have I think I remember
cutting my armpit hair once in my life
because I was like okay it's getting a
bit long it's kind of getting a little
bit
not when I was in high school oh okay
no I was in high school so like I barely
had any body hair that I needed to share
like I couldn't even grow a proper beard
back yeah so I was like okay you know
it's kind of getting long and annoying
so I'll just like maybe just go half
right yeah yeah so that it's out of the
way yeah problem is and this is the same
problem when you shave your uh genital
area is that there's a point where it
gets really [__] itchy
and it gets so annoying so like after a
while like the new hair is starting to
grow and then this itchiness just comes
and it's like your armpits are just
constantly she just turns off [__]
monkey you're just doing this the whole
that's why I never shave like all the
way I don't I don't like I don't go
right to the skin I always leave like a
little bit but I mean like I uh I've
recently discovered the power of like
shaving your armpits as well and I've
just realized how much easier it is to
get deodorant to [__] stage oh yeah
yeah like like I understand the effects
of deodorant now like and like anime
fans anyone who goes to Convention maybe
this is a [__] life hack they don't
know what deodorant because you know
sometimes when uh when I was like a
teenager I'm like my armpit hair was
like really really long no matter how
much deodorant I would spray on there or
no matter how much I would shower for
some reason there would always be this
like [__] lingering smell there that
I could never get yeah because when your
hair is long here you're basically just
putting deodorant on the hair yeah
you're basically putting deodorant on
the hair and the sweat just sticks to
the hair as well yeah
um and I love when we talk about this
[__] because I'm always diagnosed this
with someone
it's like actually that's I this happens
when I talk about the pimple on my ass
as well yeah yeah I like it someone said
what it was and I was like actually that
could be right yeah they were like yeah
I don't know that means you've been
you've been taking too much dick off the
ass yeah yeah exactly exactly no I mean
I feel like guys don't talk enough about
you know self-care and self-grooming
techniques
um I know just like it was at least uh
literally like three four years ago
where I had you know I read a group of
guys in England and we just randomly
brought up this topic and I was like
[__] this is literally the first time
I've ever had this conversation in my
life okay every okay no no sorry yeah
every guy has a different grooming
technique every guy takes care of
themselves differently and sometimes
just by talking about it you realize oh
I never shaved my armpit here before
because no one really talks
does it not get itchy not if uh I I do
it with like
um an electric razor right and I have
that's good yeah yeah like like electric
razor and I have one specifically just
for like my body and it's just like a
number one person I do I use everything
[Applause]
because I
[Music]
um
come on it doesn't matter that's like if
you were like if you got a reason you
just started you know going to town here
and then you're like well maybe it is
okay hold on it's not like that I'm not
like
it's like it's like start from the left
side it's like one of the other gifts
done right and it's like I'm I never I
never do it like I've always I've always
washed myself completely and then I
always like trim whatever it is right
but it's just the prince I don't really
I don't I don't trim my balls that often
I don't know yeah I was gonna ask how
often do you know this should be like
the perfect spot for a man yeah yeah
this this would be the person so yeah
that was the question I was gonna ask
because I was going to ask how often do
you shave your like genital area okay so
it's a TMI oh I don't think this is I
Just Vibe it out I feel I just feel it
it's sometimes I'm like [__] it I don't
have like a well monthly time to do it I
don't have that either but like if you
if you hash it out over a year how often
are you doing it
probably like once a month I reckon as
you can tell with my beard my hair grows
really quickly to the point and I have
like I have hair growing on like really
annoying parts of my body as well uh
like I I had to start waxing feed hair
right oh wow and it's not like my feet
were like furry because they'd just be
like they'd just be like men got big
feet yeah yeah they'd just be like odd
strands of hair like randomly on my feet
that would just get caught up uh
whenever I you know put on shoes or you
know uh whenever whenever I just go
about daily life and they would just get
annoying so one day I just got [__]
gotta like I said he has like a waxer so
I just like [__] just got it like got
a waxing and just [__] waxed all my
hair off my feet and I just it's just
nice now it's just nice Ellen always
talks about laser hair removal whenever
I say anything she's like you should
laser hair removal I think mailing one's
all body hair eliminated from the Earth
but she's very quick to recommend it
I've never had it I don't know who
anyone else yeah yeah yeah sounds like
it hurts I think so I've seen videos of
it of people getting it done and like I
think the ones in Japan they literally
get it because in Japan it's very common
for people to do it yes for their face
because they because in Japan obviously
clean shaven is like the look and some
people who maybe grow stubble they're
just like just get get rid of it yeah I
don't have a [__] shave this one yeah
I think uh in Japan as well a lot of
guys get what's called a Vio yeah so
it's like the V the I and then the O
what wait wait wait wait wait wait the V
is like your you know where the hair
would be like in the front yeah it's
shaped like a V yeah the I is your ass
crack yeah and the O is oh your [__]
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on hold on
what are they doing with this Vio so
basically it's the areas that they're
getting rid of the hair
oh yeah so when you get when you go get
a lot of like hair removal uh like laser
removal stuff yeah they usually ask like
where do you want it done and the most
common one is a Vio so it's just like
getting rid of all the hair there
because you know I guess the general
consensus is no one really wants uh a
hairy [__] that's true yeah which you
know I get I just I just feel weird just
searching up ass hair clinic removal
booking in a slot pulling my ass down so
I'm fine
someone just fires a [__] laser beam
at my ass
I've seen videos of it it literally
looks like a kind of like a taser and it
makes the sound of a taser like they
they press it it's clicking it is it
like clicking a bunch yeah it's clicking
a bunch I I apparently it hurts yeah
what is the deal with their hair on like
your the knuckles of your toe like what
is the evolutional point of that that's
that's that's the uh that's the hair
yeah I know I have that but it's so
[__] annoying I don't know I kind of
like it what because if I touch him my
oh it feels weird but also what is the
[__] point of that I have no I'm
looking at it I'm like this sure sure
it's there but I'm like what is the
evolutional benefit of me having four
[__] strands of hair on my like big
okay his here's the question do your
hair have like a growth limit of in
Terms like oh yeah I think so I don't
[__] trim it how long does it get
well my toes yeah on your toes I don't
know like that yeah mine's about that
and and you that doesn't bother you like
that long and it doesn't bother you no
no like that like as in like you between
about that oh like that oh my mind gets
[__] long mine gets like that which
is which I it which is why I like I
which is why I had to start [__]
waxing it because it's just gonna be a
toe yeah it just it just gets like
caught up in like so many like different
things I I saw um right I feel like I
always have to like nose hair is super
annoying for me I swear I trim it
literally one day later it's back I'm
like how the [__] does this happen yeah
and so I'm like I I was walking in the
train station and they had these little
pop-up things where they were like 20
minutes whack they wax your nose and
you're gone literally in like a train
station okay and I was like man maybe I
should do that but I've used those uh
I've used those things that you see a
lot in dollars
[Music]
you see those [__] videos people pull
and then they pull the stick out but the
wax is still there oh yeah yeah
I've done that before and it definitely
got rid of it super [__] fast but
also you need nose hair that's the thing
yes yeah yeah so it's also like it's
like earwax right yeah like I want to
get rid of it I just don't want the [__]
dangling out of my nose like some kind
of funny character yeah I feel like the
nose trimmers never work good though
yeah you hear the sound I hear the
crunch honey yeah yeah and then I pull
out I I like like I pull it out and I'm
like man I there's like still like
[__] two giant pieces but I was doing
like a full excavation I feel like nose
hairs only work if you [__] tweeze it
out that's because that's what I have to
do when like mine gets too long because
like the trimmers like you said it never
does the job I wanted to yeah I tweeze
it as well but I swear it comes back in
like two days
I have like mutant strength nose head
that just immediately spawns you just
have a spawn point in your nose I think
I do it's so goddamn annoying it's like
it's like you died spawned right back in
here maybe I should come do on this wax
thing see how it is but I also feel like
man I kind of like having the nice air
filtration and built into my body
man I also would like to have yeah
because I I definitely have the problem
of when whenever I trim my nose here's
the next day I'm sneezing like [__]
crazy yeah just because
like I I know it's like I know they do a
job but when you clean it you just never
take like a fresher breath of air in
your life I think you're mistaking
freshness for like capacity no no that's
that's the thing that's the thing I'm
like I'm like [__] time I can smell
something from demons layer like it's
just like
I wish there was a method where I could
I could like do something extremely
painful where I'll never ever see the
nose hair but it can still just be there
uh Blazer removal no no no no it's gone
limit the growth the hair that always
wants to poke out and specifically tell
those the hairs to [__] off and never
come back but the rest I can keep
because I'm fine I don't care about
having nose hair I just don't want the
ones that pop out because it's like oh
it looks [__] gross yeah all right
have you guys are people gonna [__]
enhance on this yeah yeah they're going
to zoom in on our noses have you guys
ever gone clean shaven down there yeah
yeah I've never okay here how do you
make it so it doesn't look
[__] weird I don't know it does it
always does like okay here's his here's
the Dilemma right you have like a Johnny
Sins monster [__] then it looks great
but if you have a normal sized penis it
looks weird what always weirds me out is
like my legs are like super hairy right
so so at which point do you like draw
the line you got to do like a phase
okay so it's not just like you know it's
not just like uh oh the lawn is
completely mowed but next doors is
[__] like yeah
you gotta kind of like gradually fade it
out so it looks more natural it's just
having like a patch in your like lawn
without any grass in it and the grass is
just like fun but that's what I mean
right is that like yeah sure you know
getting a clean shaven especially in the
summer it's like oh my God my balls can
breathe right so it feels good but like
it's never gonna not look weird like you
know could you like that's like if a
tree was growing in the middle of the
street you know it it looks a bit weird
right it's like a little too flat yeah
it's the same thing right so yeah yeah
yeah I I've I think I've only ever done
it maybe like once or twice but other
than that not often not often yeah I've
heard like the itchiness because I've
never done it yeah and again
I've never done like the full clean it's
just like always you know just taking
care of it a little bit of trim here and
there but yeah I couldn't I couldn't get
over just like that how do I not make
this look like my legs and my [__]
balls are just completely different the
penis is gross
yeah so it's never going to not look
weird but then again it's like did you
ever like have to did you ever think to
yourself like oh I maybe should trim
because maybe I'm going to like an Onsen
or something
no because I've seen the guys there man
the Japanese guys definitely don't give
a [__] man they don't give a [__] if
it's hiding their entire [__] penis
sometimes you can't see that PP and I'm
like is it because the hair is long or
because the peepee is short or is it
both probably for me both probably both
so you know I've never thought about
that maybe if it was like an onset in a
different country you know maybe maybe
be a bit more aware of it I'm sure
there's an evolutional need to have hair
for some reason I'm sure there's a
reason for it yeah there's always a
reason for everything yeah I don't know
do you think guys should wear makeup
okay yeah
I mean in Japan especially there's been
like a massive Trend in the past couple
years of guys wearing like very light
makeup yeah but like you know [__]
people on TV have been wearing makeup
for decades now right so it's like it's
no different I feel like if you care
whether or not people wear makeup it's
like what are you what's what's so
boring in your life you have time to
waste caring about this yeah yeah I know
I mean like I started wearing makeup
like on and off every now and again I've
done I've like been doing it less just
because I haven't really had time in the
mornings but I remember I guess like
what kind of makeup yeah I'm talking
like lipstick
it's just like very light maker most of
it was just to [__] hide bags
man I got so many goddamn bags under my
eyes yeah yeah basically it's just like
I because I was born of like bad bags
under my eyes a lot of it's genetics
because like one of them one of them I
think the three of us have bags under
our eyes yeah yeah yeah yeah because you
can do you can get rid of it right with
like surgery or some [__] it's it's I
I've looked at the effects and it it
always gets rid of the bags but I have
like bad coloring under my eye as well
and like throughout my entirely I think
we've talked about this briefly before
where my entire life it's a genetic
thing where I just look like I have
really dark under eyes and it does get
better if I get more rested but even if
I'm like fully rested have the best
night's sleep in my life I'm still gonna
have some kind of like dark coloration
on my eyes uh I wanted it to happen
sorry why does that happen it's genetics
they're like why does getting less sleep
just turn your face looking ugly I think
it's because your eyes get sunken right
is it I haven't [__] something like
that I think yeah I'm not sure exactly
what the real some some it's do of like
I guess the blood flows through uh to
your eye kind of like area as well
um
yeah so like for months I I've basically
looked up every kind of like let's say
cream or you know morning routine people
like eye packs oh yeah yeah literally I
did like ice packs I put cream on it and
um you know it's especially since I
started showing that was around the time
where I started showing my face more and
more often on the camera
um yeah it was you know it was something
I was trying to be a little bit more
aware of yeah uh and like I've been
using this for my entire life I've just
got on the uh comments from my friends
or families oh you you look like you
need to get more sleep you should get
more sleep and then you know extrapolate
that to like every [__] video I'd be
in on like a YouTube comment
um and then one day I was like I was
like Sydney uh this can sound strange
but do you have any like recommendations
of like how to like hide your eye bags
for using makeup and [__] uh because she
also does have genetically like bad eye
bags yeah
yeah yeah it doubles up yeah I mean like
so so one day she was just like oh let's
just let's let's try some you know very
like very very light makeup just like
high dry bags and it was just like a
[__] night and day kind of thing I
just started wearing it and then for
like a full-on yeah I just got no
comments about my eye bags and yeah it's
not like it's not like it really really
bothers me it's just like it was just a
nice not just just not having to like
deal with those comments yes for sure
having to explain for the millionth time
no I am getting enough sleep Mum and Dad
I am getting enough sleep I slept 12
hours long yeah I just sometimes on
camera you just look at you just look
like you just got hit by a truck it's
also sometimes just like in the case
with like a video it's just like a
lighting issue sometimes just like the
bad lighting just like enhances the bags
way more because yeah lighting is a yeah
exactly so it looks sometimes it just
looks way worse on camera than it
actually is today's episode is sponsored
by PayPal honey the easy way to save
when shopping on your iPhone or Computer
Guys we've all all been feeling the
effects of inflation recently and with
those high prices it feels great to find
a deal and thanks to Honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart boys imagine you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites when you
go to the checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is Click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site and if honey Works finding
a coupon for you you'll watch the prices
drop Joey what did you save using honey
well as you guys know I am an absolute
ring thing and I found a really nice
ring on a website that I frequently use
and I thought oh it's a little bit
expensive but luckily honey came through
and I saved a whopping 25 on the ring I
want you know you probably used it on
your laptop right Joey I did but it
doesn't just work on your laptop it
works in your iPhone and your desktop uh
just activated it's on Safari and you
can use your phone to save on the go if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll not only be doing your
off a solid but you'll be supporting the
boys as well get PayPal honey for free
at joinhoney.com trash taste that's
joinhoney.com trash taste links in the
description back to the episode do you
guys clean your ears as well often
because I know you're not mad too
because you went to the ear cleaning
clinic right did you feel better did you
feel good afterwards no I didn't like it
I did not like it at all I thought it
was disgusting I actually do it like
once every couple weeks just because
like I I don't know why maybe it's
genetics or whatever but like I my ears
produce a [__] load of wax and if it
gets left then it sometimes I've had
just like straight up Ear blockages
before because yeah the wax build up so
ever since I was a kid like my mom used
to like do that whole anime thing of
like I would like
and she would clean it out yeah I don't
know you know I go when I go shower I
just soap up you know get around this
area get in there a little bit but I'm
you know I never put mine I don't go
deep in yeah no no like if my if like
you know I just do like that like kind
of thing right I'm like all right that's
enough like I wouldn't I don't for most
people that's enough yeah yeah I don't
know I don't put a [__] like a bidet
inside my [__] why would I do it in
my ears you know what I mean
like you know what I mean like I don't
I'm just doing the rim yeah
bro like I I don't know I don't want to
push it in there I don't know if it's
because my mum also did the ear cleaning
thing ever since I was a kid it's an
Asian thing it must be an Asian thing
well like because I've heard from like a
million different places but you should
you know shouldn't use cotton buds to
like clean your eyes on the goddamn
package yeah it's what he says on the
goddamn packaging and you know doctors
ear doctors Health experts obviously
know what they're talking about but God
[__] damn it sometimes there is just
an itch in there that I just can't clear
our edges in your head though
[Music]
it comes and uh it's it's impossible to
like get rid of I've tried like other
methods because because I've read
something like the popping technique I
don't do that what the [__] is the
popping sometimes like if I really want
to like feel you know get rid of that
itching deep in my ear yeah can't be
bothered to like you know grab the thing
to like go in there I just like kind of
pop it like this yeah and it like it
kind of helps uh it's probably just
Placebo it's all in my head apparently
yeah this is all in your head I don't
think they can there's actually an edge
in your ear I think you're you're
dreaming of it but what is an edge no
yeah I mean what isn't it resource music
what is what is even a Mitch I'm itchy
or am I yeah yeah but no like I
sometimes like I I try you know just
what what they what they record what
doctors recommend is that you need ear
wax so you should just like rinse it out
and just get the towel I like rinse like
you know just like yeah just clean it yo
that that itch that itches that and I I
cannot get rid of it we'll talk about
having an itch in there now no now I'm
feeling like there's gonna be an itch
because you keep talking about it did
you but did you ever have like problems
with your ears when you were a kid no
because I used to get ear infections all
the time when I was a kid oh really yeah
yeah I've had multiple ear infections uh
in the past so I think that's just like
kind of [__] up the inside of my ears
for the most part yeah and also I have
like very light tinnitus as well enough
if I'm going to too many concerts so
that probably doesn't help I've never
really gotten sick ever really like it's
like an infection ear infection isn't
really like you know ear infection is
weird because I've only had like one ear
infection once my life as a kid and uh
because like it's an ear infection
that's where your balance sensors are as
well yeah and it was just so weird not
being able to walk yeah you know and
just it feels like you're dizzy all the
time yeah yeah yeah like you you you
stand up and you're like I don't know if
I'm up or down right now and it was it's
I've never experienced anything like
that in my life where I I literally felt
like standing up felt like I was hanging
upside down it's it's super super
[__] weird but I like I got my um I
got my ears checked when I was in
Thailand because I was like I I don't
know if watching all of these videos
like made me a bit paranoid because I'd
heard if you'd like try cleaning it with
cotton uh like earbuds like cotton buds
that you like push the wax in I was like
I want to make sure I'm not doing that
um and yeah I got it checked and
apparently it's like I I'm hoping this
wasn't the edge right because they
looked my ear and I don't know if like
when when you got your inner ears
cleaned right that was obviously like
did they take anything out of your ear
or do they just check it out oh really I
do not feel comfortable having an object
that deeply into my ear they went he
went so [__] deep in my ear yeah I
mean I like basically was on the like
the moment he took it like the [__] on
my ears went to the toilet I was like on
the toilet like like vomiting I was like
this shit's so gross this is horrible
it's a horrible experience I've nearly
fainted from eggs I was like oh really
yeah yeah it was really bad yeah I did
not like it at all yeah there was like a
single piece of uh like a single strand
of hair just stuck in my inner ear as
they were like cleaning it out and I'll
just yeah I just I'll just never forget
the feeling of just like uh like the ear
doctor was like okay whatever you do do
not move and I was like what are you
gonna do and she was like I think I see
a single single strand of hair and I was
like okay cool she's gonna she's gonna
like she's she's just gonna clean my
ears just a single strand of hair
um she sticks she sticks like whatever
she sticks and I think it's like
tweezers or something yeah and I'd never
felt something enter pierce my ears so
deeply that I could hear like every
little movement of the strain of hair
and you it's it's like everything is
like bass boosted that's that's kind of
that's that's that's kind of what it
feels like how are you not laughing
honestly you tickled a lot I was I it
took it took everything it had in me
just to sit still but holy [__] it was
so oh it felt so like yeah it is getting
like a splinter I do I don't know how
long that air that was like stuck in my
ear maybe that's why my ears were like
constantly see but now the question is
how the [__] did it get in there in the
first place could be like it's a [__]
hole in your body man it could could be
any reason I uh I remember when I was a
kid uh my my uh one of my physics
teacher came in one day and he was like
yeah I just got a [__] uh I got a
[__] moth vacuumed out my ear I was
like I was like what oh [__] I've had
that as well actually wait are you
serious but it wasn't a moth it was a
mosquito oh [__] yeah like oh [__] like
it was a mosquito that uh like because
you know Australian summer [__] a lot of
mosquitoes especially if you're outside
and I remember yeah [__] you just
reminded me so like I had this mosquito
where like there was a mosquito buzzing
around near my ear and I think I must
have like killed it close to my ear
enough that the dead mosquito went into
my ear yeah and I didn't feel it for the
longest time and then down the road I
was like oh man it feels like
something's like blocked in my ear
so when I went to the doctor yeah the
doctor looked in she's like yeah there's
definitely [__] something in there
and she pulled out like a dead mosquito
oh and I was like and I was like Ah
that's probably what it was
like that's what I mean if you swallow
10 spiders in your sleep yeah right then
spiders get in your ear yeah
God yeah that was top 10 reasons why
mosquitoes are [__] [__] why did
they do that thing when you were like
sleeping and they just like they it's
always the ear yeah like you you're
gonna hear you can hear a mosquito just
buzzing around and every soft it will
just come right by your ear I don't
think I've ever been bitten by a
mosquito
you've never been by mosquitoes maybe
you're just not aware of it
I've never seen like a like a bite on my
body from anything you also rarely go to
countries where mosquitoes that's true
we don't have them in the UK you have
mosquitoes
whenever we're out together you're like
I'm getting bit bitten by mosquitoes yes
because I'm I'm tanking it all for you
yeah and I'm like I'm like really I
never get bitten by anything ever like
I've I've noticed even like I I don't
know what it is something about my blood
maybe it's like my blood type
um but like in Thailand he has a
mosquito aggro skill oh no yeah
have mosquito aggro so like every time
we go to Thailand uh even if a mate like
normally gets bitten by mosquitoes as
soon as we hang out together they just
never get bitten because I I like tank
all the mosquito bites for them boys
like some people as well they get bit
but some people's skin doesn't react to
being bit and other people's diet yeah
it's same same with bed bugs as well
yeah yeah like some people get the red
bumps some people don't yeah
um
I used to get them really bad well bed
bugs no no mosquito bites like I I had
maybe it's because of the mosquitoes in
Australia just op but like I I used to
have days where like I don't even feel
the bite I might be like outside on my
in my backyard just like doing something
during the night and then the next
morning I'm like what the [__] is this
giant red patch I wonder if they can
tell my blood is [__] I don't know if
that's why that's a good thing they they
land and they sniff and they're like nah
there's [__]
yeah because I must have like [__]
sugar sweet blood or something because
the right concoction of vitamins and
yeah because like I I've been told when
I was a kid I was because like you live
abroad so that's that's why you get
better than a lot and like the order of
grown up the more I just realized not
even if there's a foreigner next to me
uh it doesn't make a difference I'm
still the only one getting [__] bit
it doesn't matter how long I live in
Thailand I still get like the same
amount of bites I think it's got to do
with like a number of things like your
blood type is one thing but also like
how high your blood sugar is and like
just oh all that kind of stuff just
thrown together because in Japan it's
like oh if you have uh orgata like oh
blood type uh you're more likely to get
bitten by mosquitoes
I weirdly I don't know what my blood
type is I feel like I should know do you
know what your parents blood type is no
who knows
every every six months Connor does it
say it on the paper yes it's also you
have a blood condition you should
probably be able to say it on the paper
like at the top really well when they
take the blood they're not going to be
like oh yeah so we took your blood uh we
don't know what type it is though yeah
wait wait wait wait I I only saw like I
never saw blood type yeah it has a Minds
mine says oh this is like just a letter
o yeah it's either o a b or a B oh maybe
I just didn't notice six it was under
like all the all the other A's maybe he
was like yo I scored an A in blood man
I probably just because it's pretty
Japanese yeah and I was like oh okay oh
that's good right
oh wait is it blood type wait no could
you get tested on your blood as well
right yeah yeah the quality of your
blood yeah yeah so maybe I just thought
I don't know I mean if you're getting
tested on the quality of your blood
they'll probably tell you what your type
is you're saying it's definitely there I
I'm 100 sure there's no there's no
reason for it to not be there yeah I get
I just I guess I never looked up I I
just never really noticed yeah I
probably should know this huh yeah I
mean considering you have a blood
conditions
yeah yeah true but I mean I get uh uh I
get like a factor injection not blood
injection normally like a factory
injection it's not not like what's that
it's the stuff that I'm missing I
normally don't need a blood injection to
stop the blood from
like you're gonna I can temporarily have
something in my body that will will act
normal yeah so I I don't know most of
the time I don't need a blood
transfusion or anything like that I just
I just need the missing component which
wouldn't they need your blood type for
that no no not for that oh really no
because it's in everyone's blood ah
which is the thing I'm missing right
right so that's why I think I never had
to learn it that much hopefully touch
touch with her you know you should
probably know just in case yeah yeah
just just
in case yeah I had a medical bracelet at
one point and I lost it I just never got
another one
so
I just hate bracelets too I just think
they're annoying brightness but you wear
watches yeah but it's different and
which is nice so what's what's a medical
bracelet like just tells you like hey
where my treasures hidden if I die okay
that's the one piece yeah I've not seen
anyone wear one it's like a white band
right it's like a yeah it can be y it
can be anything really it's like
engraved with information right they
normally check your engraved so it's
actually like hey
this is what he has oh so that like he's
a [__] oh he's a sick
so it'd be like hey here's hemophilia
this type of Hemophilia so they know
right away they're like oh we gotta get
some of this stuff all right
yeah yeah I guess I don't know how I
don't know how [__] probably needed
in America it has your like Insurance on
there as well hopefully no I don't know
about that I think it just says like
general information that the doctors
need in case they need to perform
anything mine just had just said like
what I had right just so I guess so it's
much quicker for them to figure out what
to do yeah and to get the stuff they
need okay okay so I did have that but I
lost it you should probably yeah yeah
she's annoying to get one she's kind of
annoying yeah but it also you know your
life's kind of dependent on it so right
it's fine it's like you know life
insurance kind of annoying to get I know
there's other stuff you can get like
some people have
this other stuff
um I know there's a technology and a
company was where basically it would
just like they could just it would send
everything to a phone and apparently I
can't remember this
can you Google this or something there's
some kind of Technology they have where
they can instantly see everything wow
like and I can't remember what it was
like a digital or something yeah
something you could have I don't know it
might have been a card that like an NFC
chip that Taps and then it could tell
and yeah [__] these poor [__] uh
EMTs are like would you get the new uh
update for this app I can't download his
life-saving medical information say
sorry my 4GS yeah
I don't I don't know like I'm I guess I
guess I'm kind of like
I'm kind of not the same but like
um like I have asthma right radio comes
up but I don't know if this uh if if I
kind of just wheeled it away off it's a
normal thing it's all in your head if
it's like if it's like a normal thing
that happens as you grow older but like
I had uh I had I had asthma as a kid and
uh it was it wasn't like horrible
horrible that's what I would call it
more like mild asthma right at like the
worst but I would have to there would be
points as a kid where I would have to
like use my inhaler right whether you
know I'd been exercising or a lot of the
times it would just like randomly come
about I don't know what exactly caused
it but something caused it
um I know this is like the wrong [__]
mindset to have right but I was I I
always saw as like a [__] I always
saw as a weakness right I this which is
the wrong [__] mindset that's very
kid way of looking it is it is it's a
permanent debuff yeah yeah because
having having I don't know how to
describe having asthma and just having
that hit of an inhaler yeah I was so
jealous of those kids I thought that was
sick when you got to do that so yo
you're doing drugs
dude that's badass
but like it's it's so weird because like
you you take the hit and you go from
like feeling like your chest is like
congested and like you can hardly
breathe to like having the clearest
breath of like like breath of air in
your life and I was just like you know
you know what every time yeah every time
I'm doing an asthma hit I'm admitting
defeat my lungs are stronger than this I
don't know why I thought this as a kid
but I would like it would only be like
to the Limit where I would be like in
pure discomfort because sometimes I'd
I'd have like a mild kind of like asthma
thing and I would just be like nah my
lungs are stronger my lungs are built
dude I just breathe I'll just literally
breathe harder and it's only like I
would wait to push it to the edge before
like I could like uh barely breathe with
just [__] stupid that's dangerous I
don't recommend that I was a dumb kid
um who was just trying to like [__]
will this asthma away but like for some
reason when I like reached teenagers uh
when I reached by like University age I
just noticed that like more and more I
just got like less asthma attacks and I
don't know what caused it
um I don't know if it's just part of
growing up or just like my stupidity
played a factor and just yeah
everybody's reacting differently to
certain situations yeah because it's
interesting because like I didn't even
know that like asthma was a thing like
that I thought it was always just like a
permanent thing where like the moment
you develop asthma you have it for the
rest of your life I didn't know it was
like a thing that just like went away or
came back I still think I have like very
very very mild asthma I haven't had to
use but it's not as bad as when you're a
kid right oh no no way no way like uh
before I would that would like I could
not travel without my inhaler just in
case
um but I haven't needed to use mine like
I still have my inhaler in like every
travel pack that I have with me uh
whenever I go travel but I haven't had
to use it in
I think it's coming on to like a decade
well I haven't had to like use it
um so it's it's it's been it's been it's
been a long time since I've had like a
proper bad asthma attack and I don't
know I don't know what factors played
into that but I just I just look back
and I was just like why why was I so
adamant on using the [__] inhaler
yeah it's I guess it's kind of the same
thing as like allergies right because
like allergies are also the same because
like you know I had [__] horrible hay
fever in Australia and I always like saw
it as defeat if I like had to pull the
tissues out in the middle of a
conversation until like my nose I'm like
no yeah I'll just [__] breathe harder
I just [__] do one of those I don't
need that but then I realized much later
on that like like doing the like the
hard disgusting like liquidy sniff yeah
is way more uncool than just getting a
tissue and just blowing that [__] out
yeah yeah but yeah I don't know there's
I I totally get that whole like it's a
weakness thing even though it's not like
[__] everyone it's like so many
people have asthma so many people have
hay fever it's like nothing to be
ashamed of but like yeah I don't know
what it is it's like something about you
being a kid just being like no I'm not
like the rest of them I refuse I refuse
I am a strong boy I'm gonna get through
this okay body [__] listen to me you
can fight through this you can just
breathe so stop being weak
we are the worst medical advisors oh my
God yeah hopefully uh yeah definitely
don't listen to us to medical advice at
all uh we we have someone with a blood
condition who does not know their blood
type
and asthmatic who refuses to use his
inhaler
give me the universal blood yeah the
universal blood the universal blood
what's that what's the one though oh
negative is that one that works at
everything or is it a b one of them one
of them you should be the one
hey hey it's the doctor's job give me
the universal one the the the C7 yeah
give me the best you got dogs give me a
top shelf
are you cooking or what so uh changing
topics uh I went to hakone again
yesterday it's been a while I've been
talking
um and uh for the first time I actually
like I guess explored some of the more
like let's say touristy areas of hakone
the pirate ship I did not go I thought
I'd heard about this pirate ship no we
uh we went up to the mountain and like
it just it just reminded me how far like
Japanese like how far Japanese areas
will push this one little thing as like
a selling
I mean Sydney so we're taking like our
friend Eugene there and me and City are
very much just yo we just want to go and
just chill out and just go to the Onsen
and chill out and Yuji is like no we I
want to explore I've heard this thing
called this like black egg that gives
you like good health and you have to
travel up this [__] Mountain to get
there
um and so it sounds like the shittiest
side quest ever it's like it's like it
is the shittiest side quest ever so we
we go up there and we're like um
and uh it takes like [__] took us
like 45 minutes to get to get up this
mountain with all like the because how
can I even though it's like a touristy
area if you don't have a car it's still
it's pretty hard to get around right
because there are no there's like
limited taxis in the area it's a very
kind of hilly area so what most people
know what most tourists do is they hire
they go to there they go to their Onsen
and then they just stay right and then
they just stay in that Onsen for their
entire duration and just relax uh so
actually like getting around to
different uh different spots is a pretty
you know pretty hard so to get up to
this uh to get up to this mountain
uh to well like I guess there are kind
of like G um geothermal activity
um The sulfur Lakes yeah it's like
sulfur lakes and stuff like that which
is
it's fine I don't know if you ever
wanted to go to a mountain that smells
like farts perpetually it's it's just
like it's literally like going there
you're like oh I'm I'm smelling Satan's
ass right now
this is what Satan's ass smells like
yeah I'm like cool let's uh let's try
this black egg that's uh Eugene has uh
excitedly like been talking about for
the past 45 [__] minutes because I
just want to go back to this Onsen
um and so we go there and we thought I
thought it would just be like one small
shack or something that's up there no
they have like this entire complex with
just it it's it's like a it's like a
two-story massive like shopping center
based around this black [__] egg I'm
like what the [__] it's a black egg like
that that is like that place is the
epitome of milking the cowgirl they have
they had a entire [__] Museum there
like what are you why is this here and
in all honesty like when you actually
find out about how they make the black
eggs it's really not that impressive all
they do is they get an egg and they
throw it into a boiling sulfur Pond for
like three minutes and then that's and
then some chemical reaction tones the
shell block when you crack open the egg
though it just looks like an egg oh it's
yeah it looks kind of like weird because
you know you see the egg and it's like
warm and it's black but I'm like you
could have just put this in [__] food
coloring I wouldn't be able to tell the
difference
um and also the egg kind of smells like
false because of the salt yeah and the
Egg kind of smells like farts so yeah
you crack it open and it's it's just a
normal boiled egg yeah I remember eating
it Eugene's like I can really like taste
the sulfur and I I took I took a bite
and I'm like this is this is like every
other building it is a hard-boiled egg
I'm like bro this needs some salt in it
man like you literally paid like what
you the amount you'd pay for like a full
pack of 12 eggs yeah one black egg and
I'm like the line to just get these eggs
was like it was the entire like length
of the shop I'm like I'm like the
Japanese are a [__] Master at
marketing the stupidest [__] thing
yeah people will travel to your
prefecture to do uh the one thing though
that's cool up there I don't know if
they still have it but they have like a
an ice cream place like a soft serve
place oh that does black soft serves but
it's all it is it looks cool because
it's like it's this pitch black ice
cream
it's just vanilla ice cream
yeah they normally put charcoal on it
yeah they put charcoal in it yeah and
that makes it yeah but when you eat it
it's just a vanilla chocolate vanilla is
actually pretty good though huh charcoal
vanilla is pretty good chocolate vanilla
is good but is it worth spending 45
minutes to go up a mountain that smells
like fast to get it yeah not sure you
ever do that [__] where you put like
charcoal on your teeth
yes
I used to use like a chocolate Face Wash
yeah yeah I don't I feel like it doesn't
work I got rid of my acne oh okay yeah
part of the problem with a lot of these
like let's say
like self-grooming self like
um likes beauty tips and stuff like that
is I don't know who to [__] trust
because let's let's be honest like like
basically all of these products are made
in a lab right yeah with some chemicals
that you'd hope help whatever the [__]
they're selling but like every every
time I like go on YouTube or go on the
internet like search up how do I get rid
of let's say I have like a bad acne day
or something what's the best way to like
get rid of that yeah a lot of the time
it's like
a lot of the time a lot of stuff like
that'll be like hey uh maybe you should
sleep more exercise and eat healthy and
then like no no no I didn't come for
that answer yeah like just you know
stand in the sunlight for a little bit
and uh go away well I I started wearing
uh
uh every morning uh for I was using face
Master a while and I kind of like it but
it's also kind of annoying so you have
to leave them on for like 15 minutes
yeah sometimes I just want to get into
streaming right away yeah and then um I
know that a lot of people said wear
sunscreen every day yeah so I started
doing that and I don't know if it I
think yeah what is the science of that
well so so obviously like even when it's
like cloudy and stuff there's UV and the
UV UV is pretty bad for your skin in
general so the idea is is that if you're
just always wearing and it's a
moisturizing cream and sunscreen and
yeah so hopefully the idea is like I get
moisturize and also protect from UVS
because he was getting sunburned in his
house
even if I'm walking outside for like an
hour I'm like I'm putting it on that's
why you don't use light mode
[Applause]
I think UV is what like kind of Ages
your skin like yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
even when I was thinking about Ludwig he
was like it was like a cloudy day and he
was like I'll check the UVS I'm like
what yeah the uv's outside I'm like why
he's like gotta see if I could have put
sunscreen almost
have you ever you you know those like
strips those like black strips that you
see like on your nose that like gets rid
of like yeah you know have you ever used
them yeah I've used it have you ever
seen it be as effective as what those
YouTube videos make it seem like I feel
like it works but not well enough to
make me want to keep doing it yeah like
I I've seen videos especially the videos
where you know the advertise it of
course of course of course it's gonna be
the videos they advertise in and it
looks so [__] satisfying just seeing
like the little pins like pop out as you
as you appeal it but what is this used
for uh getting rid of blackheads like on
your nose and stuff like that
um but every time I've seen someone do
it I swear to God it just rips out their
hair I don't know I I never see any
[__] blackheads on there they're just
waxing their face I don't know I didn't
I saw blackheads but like I found that
the results were so subpar yeah I was
like don't I don't even know I had these
like I couldn't even tell right I never
the noise I did it is because they
marketed towards me and made me think
that I had a problem and so I did it and
I was like when I guess there's
something on it but I'm like I don't
really see a difference I feel a
difference but that's just because I
peeled my skin yeah yeah so I feel I
feel different no matter what when I do
that yeah right I don't know maybe I'm
being have you ever fallen down the
YouTube rabbit hole of like those
[__] pimple popping videos bro I
can't watch those guys
I don't understand I'm calling out
people who enjoy watching people like
that yeah
oh she's left okay so no offense for
people who love watching videos like
that what the [__] is wrong with you
it's so gross I don't understand like
people say like it's satisfying and I'm
like slime videos are satisfying just
watch those no I do get it because when
you pop when I pop my own pimple or
something yeah it is kind of satisfying
yeah really when you pop your own pimple
and you get all that [__] out of it it
just hurts
no it doesn't hurt it does no I used to
have mad acne on my face when I was in
high school and so like I would
sometimes accidentally pop pimples just
by like scrunching my face
I had really bad acne no dude because
when you get a bunch out you're like
[__] a nice together yeah but then it
just leaves a [__] scar on your face
you know for long though oh sometimes
it's permanent oh really yeah yeah
that's why you shouldn't pop your paper
yeah I I actually like I actually have
some permanent scars on my face because
of it I can't tell you but it's I I have
the beard to hide it but it's super
[__] hard to not pop it because it's
just it's so satisfying yeah
dermatologists always say like don't
pause oh you're not supposed to no
you're not supposed to no because it
leaves a mark because sometimes you can
actually like push it like even like
more deeply in yeah if you pop it like
Incorrect and then when that thing
eventually pops whether you like it or
not then it [__] hurts and it can
stop bleeding yeah yeah and that's the
satisfying ones though that's that's all
you know you've got everything out but
okay but like eat
okay I get it like popping your own
pimple satisfying right because it gets
ready on your face popping other
people's pimples too yeah yeah but like
I don't want to see a rainbow person's
pimple getting popped super [__] up
close and where you can see all the
[__] pus and like [__] coming out of
it I'm like that's just gross I don't
want to see that do you think you'd take
care of yourself if you as much if you
want a YouTuber how much less would you
take care of yourself if you went on
camera uh well I can show you a picture
of when I was in high school and uh it's
pretty bad yeah I feel like I would have
been the biggest [__] Slob on earth
oh 100 I would be like 300 pounds like I
just wouldn't care yeah yeah I feel like
I take care of myself the same I don't
know I would not I would not YouTube
like the only the only thing that I've
done because of YouTube is kind of like
when I was like you know put on makeup
yeah but that was just like I would I
would have probably done that eventually
just because I would just have been
searching for a way just to stop these
[__] comments like every time I see
someone yeah
um I mean it is frustrating especially
like if uh same with like if for some
reason someone sees like a part of my
like balding area yeah every comment is
like oh my God even though it's saying
I've spoke about like a million times
yeah and it's one of those things and
unfortunately it's just like it is what
it is yeah um yeah and lighting
especially Studio lighting which is very
bright and my skin tone reflects so it's
like oh [__] yeah and it's just one of
those things where it's like I don't
care about this nearly as much as the
comments do yeah but seeing all those
comments is like dude could you talk
about the goddamn video yeah exactly
yeah no exactly that's the thing at that
I get that that's the thing and I would
never have cared about like finding ways
to kind of like you know uh make it
better yeah until uh all these [__]
comments were like hey you should you
know why why the [__] you balding that's
it bro what do you mean why yeah it's
it's not like like you have a choice
like there's some people who post on
like Reddit like oh my God Conor's
balding yeah it's like what do you mean
yes who cares I had British genetics I
was [__] from the start yeah I mean
it's yeah it's not like I wake up every
day I'm like oh my God
sometimes just like a slight annoyance
um and I'm like you know can we talk
about the thing that we want that I want
to talk about and it's you know it was
just like an easy way just to like
couple comments yeah but like even if
like I didn't have YouTube I don't know
I feel like I've never
I've never put too much effort into like
self-grooming but I've never been like
full of full-blown degenerates closet I
feel like I would be a totally different
person if I
just didn't somehow end up doing these
YouTube YouTube videos because I didn't
I didn't really care about taking care
of myself in any capacity right like I
was like I'll just do video games I
would I would the only reason I would
take care of myself without the YouTube
videos is like for my partner yeah right
like if my partner is like oh you're
kind of [__] fat then I'll be like
all right well you know what maybe best
to start getting in shape yeah you know
that honestly that's that's kind of like
the best motivation you know I I want to
stay looking good yeah for my wife yeah
I want to say you're looking good
exactly like sometimes I'm like yo
Sydney do you want me to get like bigger
muscles and like get a six-pack and
she's like no and I'm like part of me is
just like this but what if like what if
I could yo yo how much how much would
that make her happy if I did even though
she said she doesn't want to see it I'm
like maybe maybe one day I'm gonna wake
up and I'm gonna I'm gonna give it twice
all your great food and drink to get a
six-pack because I'm not
no one is worth it but I think I wanna
no no amount of physical physical
gratification will will compare to a
great beer
I don't think like the reason I said Six
Flags because I don't think it would
take me too much work to get a six-pack
just because I'm so thin yeah as it is
like I've you know when when I went to
the gym more regularly before I was like
actually like I think quite close to
getting a six-pack because it was like
starting to show just because I didn't
have to lose too much weight for the
muscle to start showing
um so that's why I'm just like maybe
maybe one so that's why I was so glad
when I I also asked the same question
Archie I was like would you like it if I
was like more toned and like you know
six-pack maybe not a six-pack but just
like more muscly tone and she's like no
I like it the way you are and I was just
like oh thank God
all right woman hand me my pizza
whatever makes you happy right yeah yeah
but of course she's gonna say that now
of course of course of course your
partner's gonna be like no honey I love
you just the way you are but if
hypothetically she said I would would
like to see you in his six-pack I would
probably try and do my best to give
myself a six-pack fair enough you know
because it's like if that's what makes
her happy then that's what will make me
happy right I'd be like damn you're in
the right you're in the wrong
relationships
I found it very um
so the the most common
um if you ever try to you know you take
uh like Rogaine or whatever any hair
medication like the main one the one
that's like the only one that's like FDA
approved whatever yeah yeah all the ads
that you you hear on YouTube and stuff
all promote whatever yeah um I just
found it so [__] funny that the one
side effect this drug so you can they're
like you can stop losing your hair yeah
okay yeah like there was a side effect
there and you're like go on it's like
there is a chance you may be impotent
and you're like wow what a cruel
trade-off you can still you can feel and
look more attractive and have your hair
but you're rolling the dice as if your
dick will work and you're like God Dad
yeah that's the site like it could have
been anything it could have been like
depression weight gain any of those
things
it's like it's like it's like they you
it's like a movie plot you couldn't
design this side effect more perfect for
what they're called yeah like you know
that's the equivalent of being like you
could have the sexiest six-pack to get
anyone that you want but you have to get
a vasectomy yeah yeah yeah but no way no
that does that way I don't think that
would be as much of it we certainly
still have the dick jokes
we got a chop your dick off yeah but
yeah because I I remember because uh I
was I I had this conversation with uh
didus like yeah uh before as well
because uh I told him that uh I I was
also taking uh yeah he seemed to believe
that it would just you no matter what if
you took it your people don't work I
told him I'm like no no no so if if you
do research I believe there is uh one
percent chance it's small it's it's a
very very small chance I believe it's
one percent uh that you'll just get
impotency maybe not since when you you
feel it's not I was less it's like
you're way less you have like way less
desire for sexual activity and you could
could your BP might not work as much
yeah yeah in that in that department so
what if that matters to you yes so so
yeah I I told the artist that yeah I
take this as well the first thing he
says yeah the same [__] thing to me
yeah the first thing he says to me is yo
did you win the gotcha and I was like
what what do you mean what do you mean
he goes the dick gotcha did you win and
I was just like oh wait yeah maybe okay
so I had the conversation with him where
I was like he was like yeah I don't know
if I should have taken it and I was like
well I wish I did research sooner
because like it completely pretty much
stopped any kind of yeah aggressive hair
loss like it's so it's a kind of it's
just normal now yeah it's not normal but
like it doesn't get worse and it got a
little bit better yeah um and so I was
like dude if you're even thinking it
might happen you may as well just
[__] if you're worried about it just
start now before you actually are
balding and yeah or your hairline
recedes and you're like oh well because
there's no way there's no way to regrow
hair that's lost without getting a
[__] transplant or something uh the
only way that you can stop yourself uh
stop you from losing hair is prevention
so you need to get there before I know
this sounds like an adverb yeah this is
like literally okay this is literally
like the keeps ad read but that's
because it's like I I did my research
even before getting it or you could just
I used to think it was so cringe All
Those ads that were promoting it yeah
it's [__] stupid now I'm like God
damn I wish I [__] started
because you know you I think you always
think and I I was very guilty of this as
well like yeah because you just when
you're growing up and you have hair for
[__] 20 years you just always think
this is never gonna happen to me yeah
yeah you you always think that and then
like maybe you notice one day I think
yeah do you remember the first time you
noticed
do you feel comfortable sharing yeah
yeah I mean like I I mean I I believe
I've told you this in private but uh I
knew I was gonna vote basically uh every
one on my dad's side uh was is just bold
and has you know even if they haven't
completely lost their on on the top of
it uh they've all lost their head it's
something tell them sooner why don't we
know sooner yeah so I remember because
you know I
this was back in like the Sasuke hair
phase right right I my favorite face I
like my hair okay and not not that not
that you know I don't think I could pull
off like a bold thing I just don't I
just don't know if um it's I don't know
I just don't know if I'm ready for it to
be like my identity I mean no you know
what I mean you've had the benefits
of that phase I know I can pull it off
but you know I'd like it to be instead
of be like a choice I'd like it to be a
choice rather than a choice that's
thrust upon me right right uh so I
remember when I was like you know 17 18.
I was like Dad uh everyone on your side
of the family is bold and I remember
like what started this conversation was
I remember seeing a picture of my dad uh
when he was like you know in his like
20s uh and he he had he had a lot of
hair yeah he had hair down to [__]
here he's had he had more hair yeah yeah
he's had more hair than I ever did in my
life and I was just like oh Dad you used
to have a lot of hair he's like yep yeah
thanks for bringing it off and I was
like uh so like out of curiosity when
did you start losing it and he was like
oh my God I don't remember I think it
was like around like 30 or something
I've never been nice I've I've never
forgotten this conversation in my life
because I remember I this this
conversation is engraved in my mind
because as soon as I heard that as soon
as I hit 25 I was like start taking
pictures I started I started taking
pictures and it's it is literally you
going through the five stale the five
stages of denial yes you do right
because like I must have just I must
have just part of it yeah
my hair doesn't go on this side yeah
yeah everyone has a little dog yeah of
course so like I started regularly
taking pictures of like my scalp uh
since I was around the age of like 25 26
and I was like I've been the genetics 25
years old I pulled the gotcha yeah yeah
at age 26. my dad's talking [__] I have
a full head of hair baby 27. oh maybe
that's maybe that's a bad uncle is that
a bad angle that might just be a bad
angle I still look good baby age 28 nah
I mean like that's that's like a normal
hairline that's you know everyone who
gets old has like a little bit of like a
little bit of receding uh recession
there I forgot what it was called huh
that's just a widow speak that's just a
widow speak age 29 uh this is when I've
like fully moved to Japan for like you
know uh like the first year yeah I was
like
it could be it could be uh like I'm I'm
you know what you know what you know
this is this I know this looks like a
bad picture I know this looks like a bad
picture but maybe maybe it's just uh
maybe it's just a bad picture bad
lighting bad lighting and uh you're
gonna get a new phone yeah yeah yeah and
it was when like it was when I hit like
the age of like 30. I just had like that
was like one awful picture and there was
like one video where I believe like the
back of my head was showing up I think
it was might have been like the drifting
special or something and I'm like I'm
like okay acceptance time yeah I am I am
losing my hair but it still doesn't look
super it does it doesn't look too bad so
that's when I started doing like a lot
of research into this
um and ever since I started taking uh
started taking the pill
um it's not gonna it's not gotten any
worse it's gotten like slightly better
nowhere near as good yeah as when I
started tracking it when I was like 20
25 or whatever but it's not gotten any
worse you know which is which is a good
thing which is a good thing yeah yeah it
was yeah it was very strange I did have
to tell you the story about how I I
asked my dad how he lost his hair no I
was like I was like Dad how did you uh
because you had to hit like a giant bald
area and I was like how did you how did
that happen he straight up [__] lied
you lied to me I escaped from a house
fire and he said that like while he was
working something dropped on his head
and that ever since then he hasn't been
able to grow hair there and it's a
[__] kid I just believe him and so
going into my adulthood I just had that
in the back of my mind when I think
about it and then now I realize the
[__] lied to him why would you
not just tell his kid that hey I you
bald sometimes you just lose it yeah
because the [__] in my family's case I
wasn't even the one that brought up the
question my parents used to just [__]
give me [__] about it being like
[__] you're gonna go bowl yeah
you're like what the hell because like
my granddad went like started like
actually getting like a full patch here
at like 26 22 yeah I mean and he was
like it sucks to be you Joey that's
gonna happen to you and I'm just
[__] my pants like you know all
throughout High School I feel like
that's the right way to go about it yeah
because I feel like I I wish I was like
talked about to me more yeah it could be
a thing that could happen that hey if
you want to do something about it yeah
one thing I've realized one thing I've
realized right
especially especially in this case the
only reason the only reason I was like I
was super attentive about like my my
hairline and whether I was going bold or
not uh because swear to [__]
God every time I'd ask a loved one if I
if I looked any worse they they'd they'd
just be like no you're not boating don't
worry about it honey whether it's like
[__] Sydney or my mum my mum my mum
full-on Asian [__] mom being like
honey you're not gonna Bowl don't worry
about it it's just it's just in your
head and it was only when I showed her
pictures of when I turned 30 that she
actually just like yeah and I was like
Mom this is my hairline right now yo you
want to go back on your word because if
I weren't taking pictures this is where
I'd be right now Mom yeah I mean to be
honest like if I ever see like a little
like you know you see a little bit of
hair like someone's head through the
hair you're like oh well it's not you
know you don't think of it as like a
bald spot just like I could just see
that scalp yeah but I guess when it gets
bigger is when it's you know there's a
very thin line between when it looks
like you're balding and when it's just
like a yeah yeah
um but you know you keep track and then
you notice I remember one time
oh my God I spent like 21. and I just
was like huh just saw something in the
mirror because I somehow saw the back of
my head and I was like that's
feels like my hair has been done
differently yeah it definitely wasn't
there when I checked a few months ago
and I was like no I can't pull them like
21. that wouldn't happen yeah but yeah
sure enough it was yeah and it wasn't
getting any worse for a while and then
it suddenly just got started getting a
lot worse and I was like oh [__] I gotta
do something about this yeah uh oh I
gotta just shave it all off yeah which
I'm happy to do but I'm like man it'd be
a nice time for a few more years what's
the point for you where you were just
like all right it's gonna go
um I guess if it ever gets to the point
where it just from no matter what kind
of like because right now it only looks
really bad if
like Studio lighting is shined on my
[__] head and yeah very much see a
angle of my head right all right well
that just looks like [__] yeah but you
know in a normal day it doesn't look
that bad and you can't tell unless I'm
like [__] showing you my goddamn
Scout and it's like all right well I may
as well just enjoy having hair for a
little while and then it gets the point
where if it always just looks bad or it
always looks like it's thin down I'm
like well I'll just get rid of it yeah
I'm not too worried about it I'm pretty
am I touching it now
I'm like you know if it ever looks like
[__] I'll just shave it all off I'm not
too bothered about going bold I I'm kind
of like no whatever but if I can enjoy
it but there's that weird stigma Riot of
people being like Oh I don't want to
like lose it all so they just like try
and [__] hold on to it because
they're oh yeah going bold and I'm like
there's nothing wrong with being bold
yeah I'm I'm kind of you know that'll be
uh the next Arc in my life there's a lot
of dudes who look [__] great yeah
yeah I'm just I'm just enjoying it now I
think it's the choice thing because I
yeah I want a choice yeah yeah it's it's
not about not being able to rock a bold
look because so many guys lies con it's
about having the choice of having like
because it kind of just feels like an
identity right because once you once you
like commit to being bold it's kind of
it's kind of like a big identity shift
yeah right and it's like yeah you know P
A lot of people rock it and like [__]
good on you guys you know but I feel
like a lot of guys are just like I could
Rock The Bold look but I I like having
the choice of whether I can like style
my hair or not or just being stuck with
this stuck with this one look for my
entire life it would be pretty [__]
hilarious if trash taste goes on for a
lot longer and it just ends up being
three balls
yeah but like any advice like any guys
who are worried about this oh like just
just honestly keep track of it because
yeah you you're like your memory sucks
your memory [__] sucks if you think
if you think that you're balding you
probably are boating you know because
like you you'll be like oh I don't know
did I look any different one year ago
let's be honest you don't remember what
you look like one year ago you don't
remember if it's receded like one
millimeter or whatever but if you
actually genuinely take pictures that is
like concrete evidence of okay this
there I am I'm actually progressing uh
my hairline is actually progressing and
I can like visually see it versus just
you asking a mate being like do I look
like I'm balding because they're gonna
say no yeah because uh if if we see them
unless it's like super significant yeah
unless it's super significant but at the
end like if you see someone every day
you don't like normally see like a clear
change like I remember I still always
remember this where Conor talked about
like being a bit overweight before like
trash days and [__] like that and in my
mind I was like kind of stalking [__]
someone is actually talking [__] but
I've seen Connor so many times that like
his weight change before like he moved
to Japan and before like he started
taking YouTube more seriously like his
weight change was so gradual to me that
yeah
I didn't register it at all because now
when I look back and look like old
photos of when you guys were like first
visiting Japan yeah yeah I'm just like
oh yeah yeah wow okay yeah yeah it
definitely was bigger yeah yeah like I
you know I was losing him pretty
healthily like the way I was losing it
yeah yeah I wasn't doing it like rapidly
I wasn't like overnight yeah you know I
was I was stuck to eating the chicken
and broccoli for like four or five
months and worked out a lot yeah you
know I'm sure sure [__] I lost weight
exactly [__] sucked but it was way
easier as well because I I didn't have
as much of a social life like I found
now that having a social life and going
out and and talking to people and having
dinners people is so much harder to
actually like keep like on uh like an
actual diet for me yeah but it you know
and it requires a lot more self-control
and back then it was a lot easier for me
because I had the opposite problem where
like I used to be yeah I mean you look
at like the first episode of trash taste
it was like crazy oh yeah I remember
that I look like a different person
yeah you know how how even just a few
like a not even a not even going from
like uh like it's not like you ever got
like overweight or underweight but like
just how changing your weight in any
capacity yeah yeah really makes you look
different but you don't notice it in the
moment no yeah not at all I've been uh
considering so Sydney recently has
gotten uh like ICL it's kind of like eye
surgery yeah uh and I think I think my
astigmatism's gotten worse again I don't
know some there's Sometimes some I I saw
this uh really interesting it's it's
I've you know I find information in the
weirdest way sometimes and there was
just this random Twitter thread just
detailing the detailing the uh like what
people with astigmatism see and I've
never just had a moment where just this
holy [__] moment that just like me for
real because I just thought there's so
many things that I just thought were
just everyone saw and then I saw this
thread detailing this is what you have
uh this is what things will look like if
you have astigmatism and uh this is
going to sound like the biggest [__]
excuse of all time but you know there is
a reason why I find light mode easier to
read and follow and like did this thread
details yeah you actually like the way
that the lighting works and the ways
that you see like perceived letters and
thin uh thin details things are clearer
if it's uh light mode is probably the
thing that's giving you a statement
system
this is like a never-ending Loop of like
oh my eyesight [__] use light mode use
light mode my eyesight gets worse yeah
but uh Sydney got these uh sending ICL
surgery recently and I've never been
more jealous of someone in my life just
she like she just wakes up every day and
she's like my God I have perfect
eyesight it's even better than ever wear
contacts I know right [__] [__]
what does it feel like guys what does it
feel like tell me tell me yeah because I
remember I saw I think it was a Twitter
thread or a writer thread or something
like years ago
um of like this guy who used to do like
watercolor paintings of like Landscapes
and he would like paint the same like
picture differently depending on what
your eyesight level was so like the
worst eyesight you had the more like
faded out the same picture looked yeah
and I remember I saw that back in like
you know the beginning of doing YouTube
and stuff like that and I'm just like oh
that looks like it [__] sucks yeah
and so I started wearing the blue light
glasses because I was just like well I
don't want my I don't want to [__]
wake up looking at that yeah I'll try
and prolong it as much as possible
obviously my eyesight is going to get
worse the older I get that's just like
natural deterioration like I don't want
it to like increase considering I'm
staring at a [__] screen all day for
my job right yeah
but uh yeah I really I really want to
get it but I'm I don't know I I have
this issue called just being chronically
lazy
I remember seeing this YouTube video
right that's uh that details like girls
what do you not understand about guys
right and uh one of the uh replies in
this uh Reddit thread was I don't
understand why guys would just refuse to
go to an appointment unless you
specifically book it for them and force
them to go and I'm like [__] I've I've
never been called out so more like so
accurately in my life yeah because like
I I've I've realized that I will never
like I could have like an issue that's
been bothering me for like months and
months and it's all sorted by just going
to like just sorting out like a simple
appointment but I I will never do it
myself unless like my unless [__]
Sydney does it for me I I have that
exact same problem with like not even
like appointments just like places I
want to go
oh that looks pretty sick and then I'll
talk about it days later and Aki's just
waiting being like so we're gonna go
yeah or what and the only reason I go is
because she books It Forward I've always
wanted to go and I'm like why did I
never just do this myself
oh my God why is that a thing and yeah
and another comment was another comment
which was just like uh this this one
Cindy asked me this all the time right
where uh like a girl like walks past
each other in the street they have like
a five second conversation and they
could tell like what their best friend
has been doing for the entire past two
weeks guy goes on a tramping uh guys
going on a camping trip together spends
like three days together you go back
home and she asks what do you guys talk
about and you just go
yeah every time I go out drinking with
the boy yeah right right every time I'm
just like we even have it with trash
days as well I mean like I come home
from a trash taste recording hockey's
like oh what did you guys talk about in
this episode I'm like nothing much [__]
what did we talk about
okay nothing important
cannot understand how you could spend
the entire weekend with all of these
guys and not know what you guys talked
about like how does that work what's
that Meme of like the girlfriend like
lying in the bed being like they're
probably talking [__] about the other
girls and then the guys are just like I
don't [__] remember what we're
talking about most conversations feel so
inconsequential like they're just kind
of like normal Sensations where like I
don't even remember like conversation
I'm like that was weird yeah right yeah
that's unusual I know I I just know
sometimes like even I can have like you
know sometimes I do have like deep
conversations with my fellow Bros but
put in the moment of just like what did
you guys talk about my ability to like
to like get that memory back is just
like impossible unless there's something
that reminds me oh yeah I had this
conversation and we talked about this I
remember all the details of the super
deep conversation that we had but if you
ask me oh what'd you guys talk about I'd
be like oh [__] meanwhile girls have
this like [__] perfect photographic
memory yeah every little thing they
talked about so much so to the point
where they start like dissecting it with
you and it's just like all right all I
asked was what did you talk about yeah I
wasn't waiting for an analysis yeah if
if there's one thing that I've noticed
as okay as a guy something I will never
understand about girls right
um is sometimes you you are talk uh you
know you meet uh you meet girls that are
like really good friends and it's just
like the moment I know that there are
girls who are like super super good
friends is for some reason like they can
tell when each other's periods are
coming and I'm like I'm just like that
that is that is something that is beyond
my level of understanding and I thought
it was just like a one-person thing but
the more girls I talk to the more I'm
like oh no yeah I I I know when all my
mates everyone just have like Tundra
levels
I smell one percent more iron in the
Years yeah it's like girls I know what
everyone's menstrual cycle is actually
like I'm just like this this is not a
chart right yeah this this is something
that is beyond my level of understanding
as a guy you know I don't I don't know
how accurate it is for girls but I see
it I hear it about it every so often
like in conversation uh when I talk when
I talk to me while guys don't even
realize if another borrowers had a
haircut
it's like it could be the most obvious
and you'd be like two hours into a
conversation with your friend and being
like oh did you get a haircut by the way
why are we so dumb
you just don't pay attention yeah
clearly not yeah because when it when it
changes too much like like uh like our
producer uh who who had dyed his hair uh
one day yeah completely blonde and I
remember them in my first reaction when
walking into the office uh because the
hair color was different was I don't
recognize this person it wasn't like
yeah
God why are we like this the absolute
state of men man also like also I don't
know if it's the thing necessarily about
girls but it's always moms right okay
moms in particular
no when you've lost a little bit of
weight or you've gained a little bit of
weight even if you're not aware of it
it's just like every time it's like I
could be meaning like a friend's mom or
like you know a friend you know just
some mom of a friend that I know or
whatever
yeah just I meet a lot of moms you know
yeah I should probably I should bring it
along yeah
and they're always just like you gain a
bit away or you've lost a bit of weight
and I'm like no I haven't I feel like
listening and then I go home and I check
and I'm like wow I have lost a bit away
how the [__] did you know I feel like
there's a that's an Asian mom thing they
can always tell they have they have like
a scale in their minds Asian mom
conversation style 101 bro there are
some mom abilities that I just don't
[__] understand like how is it okay
how is it that you've misplaced
something you've spent the entire
[__] day looking for this like mobile
phone or keys or something that you've
misplaced you're like Mom I don't know
what this is they have a [__] radar
built into their mind to be like I know
we've misplaced it I'm gonna find it
within one second Auggie has like
superhuman abilities with that [__] like
I could be like something super
insignificant like oh I do you know
where the role of tape is I [__]
searched everywhere in this house and
she's just sitting on the couch being
like uh my room second drawer right at
the back and I go there and it's there
I'm like what the [__]
why I play stuff oh yeah I I put like
trackers on everything that's important
yeah you do I have trackers on my wallet
I have trackers on uh my expensive
headphones I have trackers on my keys my
passport my bike yeah I have like a
track on everything that's kind of
valuable and I need because it's not
even that I I got tired of losing it
potentially like permanently it was like
I was tired of that [__] five minute
[__] where I left to look around my
house yeah to find where it is I'm like
you know what I just want to get rid of
that I'm just gonna have it so that if I
lose it I'm like all right let's play I
I've done this thing now where I've had
the exact same problem because I had a
bad habit of just leaving [__] all over
the house I now have this thing where I
just have this one little box that just
has all my important [__] in it no I I I
have that too but I somehow just he's
still losing it I put [__] in the wrong
place sometimes skill issue so uh yeah
that's been very helpful for me
um except I have these like running
headphones that I like as well and
they're too small to put a tracker on
yeah and so I keep losing them still and
it's driving me insane I I tried that
once
um and then how do you trackers work so
do you have like a beeper yeah it's a
good thing and it plays a little ringing
sound the tile things yeah yeah I have
top I I don't think they're as good as
the uh Apple one but yeah
um they they work well enough yeah I
lost the thing that beeps like so oh
it's just an app on my phone oh it's
just an app yeah I'd probably lose my
phone to like wow I'd lose the thing to
find the thing that I've lost it's the
best thing I need my keys where's my
phone [__] where's my phone here's the
best thing about it if you have any of
the things there's a button that you can
double tap and then it rings your phone
oh for example let me show you so I'm
gonna okay yeah this is an advertise
like my wallet right I have this this
card that goes in there yeah then I
press this button twice
whatever
oh cool and that's my phone yeah yeah
that's how it works is that easy isn't
that easy see I I have okay but here's
the question
what if you lose your phone and your
wallet then as long as I have one item
that's still my my bike my keys my
passport right as soon as I have
something that I can then I'll be fine
all right see I I feel like because uh I
do have I do have a finder and uh
um like Aki I I I feel like there must
be like some it must be something to do
with maternal instincts right because
yeah what I've noticed is that when we
first started dating we've done for like
almost 10 years now she wasn't she was
she was as [__] as me she was she just
didn't know where she would place things
I would ask her if she'd seen one
certain thing that I'd misplaced and she
would nowhere near find it and then in
like the past two three years she's
suddenly just gained this ability to be
to be like uh yeah uh your keys are in
the top drawer by your bed uh you left
them there and I'm like how the [__] do
you know this how when did you develop
this ability
and I'm like they're playing Sims in
Creative yeah yeah yeah you see the
whole house from like down being like
it's right there
and I'm like oh no is this is this a mum
thing that's like being developed here
it must be is this a maternal is this a
superpower that is definitely not a dad
thing it is not a dad thing at all we're
just getting stupider maybe or it's a
dad thing where like the mum thing is
the Superhuman strength to find [__] the
dad thing is the Superhuman strength to
lose [__]
so it just balances out perfectly I like
the idea that every time you just come
you get stupider your body thinks like
you're becoming a dad you're just like
oh you're a dad so now you become every
time you know you just lose an IQ point
yay all right do you feel like you are
more like your mum or your dad or
somewhere perfectly in between
[Music]
so we didn't know how to tell you this
song but you did it for us
maybe more like my mum I feel like I'm
nothing like my dad I don't know it's
very tough right do you feel like you
have a lot of common with your mom and
dad I feel like when I was when I was
like a kid right I was way more like my
mum I don't know I I had like a
I think that's very common with Suns
though yeah like like I think like Suns
when you're younger you yeah very much
you know go after your mom yeah even in
terms of like looks as well yeah and
then as you get older you start to look
more like your dad because I was
definitely that like when I was a kid I
looked like full [__] Japanese kid I
looked exactly like my mom yeah and as
I'm getting old I'm looking less like my
mom more like my dad I feel like that
that way in personality as well right
the more I go the more I grow older the
more I'm like [__] you know [__] this is
something my dad would do so this is
something my dad would say and my mom my
mom's I'm gonna call her my mom for us
like my mom's been like in full [__]
copia mode for the past like three years
because I'm like I keep doing things I'm
like I feel like I'm becoming my dad my
mom's like no you're still like me okay
you're still like me you're still my son
you know you're more like me and I'm
like Mom
my dad I'm not gonna lie my mom's just
like pointed out why does my mom want
you to be more like you I don't know I
don't know it's just the pride yeah it's
just it's just the prize
you should develop more things from me
because I am more yeah I've been
noticing like I even sound like my dad
now it's to the point where I pick up
the phone and people think it's my dad
sometimes yeah I have that too did you
have that as well my grandma mistook me
for my dad once I've never had that yeah
it's it's scary and also just like
there's just the small little things
that you notice is just normal now until
someone points it out being like you
didn't used to do that like even just
like doing that thing of like when you
come back home and you sit down you you
make that kind of
like sound
like I never used to do that well my
favorite thing is there's a there's a
shot of you as you like I don't know why
you I think you're in one of your manga
coffee videos you're like looking at
like the books yeah you're looking at it
like shut your [__] old man
and like be you're like you're holding
like your one hand in the pocket one
hand on coffee going
there are so many times where I find
myself now in everyday life doing the
the dad uh the dad stand yeah where you
just kind of when you're looking at
things you just like
like that's like what is this
I have notice you've been doing that
yeah actually I never used to do that so
I'm getting old I hate it
is it just like you reach a certain age
and just every dad just agrees to like
do the same thing and have like the same
sense of humor must be as well it must
be did you do you think Dad jokes are
actually dad jokes or were they funny at
their age and then they just couldn't
stop me no I've I've just come to the
conclusion now that dad jokes used to be
not funny now I find them [__]
hilarious
look look it's the irony thing it's the
irony cycle where you start saying
something ironically and you're like I'm
saying it ironically because haha I'm
getting old and then somewhere along the
line I start saying it because I
actually I say it I'm like I start
laughing to myself I'm like [__] like
it's no longer ironic yeah you get to
the point where you say something in a
facetious tone not only because you want
the message to come across but you also
just find it hilarious
wait just like you say something
facetious and then there's a voice in
the back of your head that was like nice
one Joey
I hate that we were able to oh my God no
I'm not I'm not becoming like myself
I'm not I'm not I don't think I'll ever
get there you'll get there don't worry
you're British
I won't I'll always be fun
I'll always be hip with the kids I'll
always be one with their fellow
generational excuse
I feel like I feel like as you know
if you don't have YouTube If you don't
have YouTube you'd probably grow more
into like your dad I get that I get that
energy yeah you know she does very
chilled very relaxed you know as like
one of the most he's a bloke man he's a
bloke you know enough
just living his best life man watching
football drinking beer that's what he
does meanwhile I'm just becoming more
and more like my dad and it's like I
don't know if that's a good thing or not
because my dad's pretty cool but yeah
it's uh warring yeah I'm definitely
becoming like my dad I've realized The
more I've grown all of them like the
more my dad just finds comfort in just
doing nothing and just being chill with
life and it's like for him to like go
out and do something it's like my mom
that has to like pressure him to be like
oh let's go here let's go visit this
person and it's not like my dad doesn't
enjoy it but my dad will refuse my dad
will never do it if it's just by his own
volition and I'm like [__] this is this
is just me and Sydney the moment the
moment you guys can start calling me out
is if we ever go out drinking and then
in mid-conversation I go oh sorry boys
I'm [__] [__] yes I remember you did
that once do you remember that you
The Race Is Gonna Keep increasing as I
get older
I'll say
I do not believe that there are people
who do not piss in the shower uh that's
that's a genuine belief because I I
could not imagine you know I'd
understand if it was like a communal
shower or whatever like that you know if
you're sharing like a public shower okay
yeah you know I didn't do that at my
University dorms or whatever but in your
own house come on why yeah I pissed him
on Joe yeah yeah we all agree with that
yeah yeah yeah well you were like no
second ago well I try not to oh yeah I
try and like pee before I go on the
shower yeah but you're about to like
flush a bunch of water away with the
shower anyway if it's yellow let it
mellow
unless
it's like yellow I I just let that [__]
mellow out oh my God asparagus day yeah
oh asparagus day yeah I'm flushing that
[__] but
sometimes yeah I mean if if it's yellows
you just you gotta flush that [__] man
that's that [__] stinks yeah but
sometimes you if you've been drinking a
lot of water your piss is like basically
clear I just drink it
on top
no like if you've been drinking a lot of
water or just you know drinking a lot of
fluids then your pee is like very clear
and in that case you're not going to see
the difference and it's not going to
smell so I'm just like sometimes I just
can't hit the first morning pee Oh first
morning piece like Giga yellow that's
always just so like
yellow oh
[__] you're froth I can get some frothy
frothy we get a Bud Light piss what the
hell sometimes like the the force that
it goes in it just bubbles up oh my god
oh it's gross sorry do you like the
feeling first thing in the morning you
know sometimes it's like a cold day or
something like that uh I don't know why
I like this feeling uh because I only
get it when I wake up first thing in the
morning but you have a good quality
Shake
what do you get that in the winter what
when when it's like a really really cold
day
and you're holding in a piss and while
you're peeing your body just kind of
like that I have had that I have had
that I didn't know I didn't know that I
know exactly what [__]
it's because I I remember I looked into
it because I was like why the [__] like
what is wrong with me and so I looked
into it apparently that's your body's
way because you're releasing a lot of
heat from the inside your body because
your pee is yeah body temperature right
so the body releasing all of that heat
all at once your body just goes into
like a little like a shiver because now
your core body temperature is a little
bit cooler have you have you ever tried
pissing in the dark
what do you mean of course I have yeah
yeah how good how good is she gonna make
it my aim Square how good is yours oh as
in like in the middle of the night yeah
okay it's the middle of the night okay
you're with a group of people yeah and
uh you don't want to turn the lights on
um and also you don't want to piss on
like the water as well because you know
they'll wake people up I just sit down
you just sit down [__] I should do that
I just sit down now I'm like I've had
too many instances where I thought the
bowl was here it was actually over here
and I'm like oh that sounds like it's
not going in the ball at all and I
turned the line on like
foreign
because I don't want to Blind myself
yeah sometimes you know you don't want
to blind yourself and sometimes you just
don't want to wake people up as well
okay yeah I don't know I'm gonna wake
them up I don't for me if I I appear
with the door open I guess yeah yeah
actually I I if if I piss at night I
never turn the lights on just because
when I turn the lights on even if it's
just like why are you on nightmare
difficulty for pissing dude I don't know
like my because my brain my brain weird
as soon as I see like lights it's like
my brain my brains like signal to be
like wow you wake up now why is this the
only time you're going dark mode
middle of the night to be fair because
my brain is wide in a way to to be like
if I see lights mode or if I see let me
wake up I'm going to wake up and I've
had it a few times where like the worst
thing is is like I I because I know
because I know how my body works and
sometimes the worst thing is when I have
like a midnight [__] and when I just
wake up someday and I'm like I need to
[__] and I sleep better after I have the
poop
yeah yeah but like if I pee when I I
really needed to pee it helps me get to
sleep so so my parents actually uh last
time I went back to my parents place
they figured out the perfect oh my God
your [__] toilet they had [__] LED
lights underneath no way I literally I
remember I I went home last time and
it's been like first time I went home
since covert right so I'm like I'm
looking around the house looking for
small chains of being like Oh that's
moved or like they added this or
whatever I walk into the toilet and just
immediately game a toilet it's just like
blue LED it does look like uh like
republic of gaming
but I was like this is so genius because
now I don't have to sit down because I
can see exactly where it is and it's not
blinding I love sent pissing them so I
prefer way prefer it I don't mind it
what do you mean it's my preferred
go-to's but sometimes it's just gonna
revolved into like pull my pants all the
way down you know you pull them all the
way down you know from their [__]
ankles every time right from a little
bit there I can't sit press bro why I
don't know my my you know you know me of
my like shits right as soon as because
sit down Eagles
what is going on with your simple chimp
brain we're sitting down makes you want
to poop okay you know me I I hate the
feeling of like not being like empty if
if I sit down and poop I'm if if I if I
don't empty myself you can empty
yourself and sit down with peeing yeah
but like if I sit down sometimes it's
like oh this is all like this is a half
this this has gone from uh like a quick
one minute pee to like a half hour
you've nerfed yourself oh you've snuffed
your entire body for somebody sometimes
my body I like I overcome this feeling
can't get past it I've learned to live
with my body I I know my body's limits I
don't know the name of your [__]
autobiography
with my body yeah yeah if I sit down
there at times when I'm like oh [__] I
need to go and then as as soon as like
that as as soon as that has hit my brain
I'm like oh I'm stuck here now I can't
stand up until until yeah you have the
fan you feel like as an adult you're
just bewild like you're beholden to the
weird
perks you've picked up from yeah being a
kid and that you're like well I can't
change anything now
there's there are some perks that I have
picked up like I used to be able to
sleep no matter what the situation was
anywhere
um and now I'll sleep just sleep is just
it's not harder but there are like
certain I've noticed there are certain
preset conditions for me to get a good
night's sleep and I've never like I've
never had that before in my life I need
I need okay what is the for me I need
the room to be pitch [__] no yeah I
can't have any amount of light I'm like
if if the curtain is like slightly open
I'm just gonna [__] all the way yeah I
know it makes no difference but I found
that
no I can't do it I love waking up and my
room is [__] bright as [__] oh yeah I
don't mind that in the morning but the
problem is is that like the light coming
from outside during the night keeps me
up
oh no it doesn't do that yeah so I need
to be like completely like basically the
equivalent to just shutting your eyes in
a darker in order for me to sleep a lot
of light in my window so I guess it's
fine yeah I have like a big [__]
window in my bedroom so it's like I need
that curtain all the way closed yeah no
proper light at all part of the reason
that I felt so tired every day on tour
uh was just the fact that I was not
waking up to natural sunlight yeah
because of that reason like my body was
just like continually tired as after I
worked yeah I hated it I I need sunlight
to wake up I thought we had this
conversation as well yeah yeah yeah
exactly I think that's just like
everyone though right I I feel like I
know really no Chris absolutely does not
want the curtains open or blinds open at
any point it's like whenever we share
rooms I'm like oh my God we have to
[__] like bunker the whole [__]
room down to make sure one crumb of
light doesn't get in the room wake up at
Furious in the middle of the night yeah
I think that's why I you know kind of
gel with Chris whenever we're sleeping
in the same hotel room problem is still
can't get to sleep because he snores
like a [__] goddamn land
yeah um I need like a half hour to an
hour cool down period before I actually
like like some people can just like go
to sleep like that I need like I need
like a cool down period when I just lay
on the bed and just chill out like Get
Low to sleep uh yeah I'm the equivalent
of like when you turn your computer off
and then it starts updating yeah yeah
I'm pretty tired by the time I get to
bed so as long as I get in a position
that my I think my brain has tricked
myself like this sleeping position yeah
I think I fall asleep pretty quickly
yeah like like as like I was saying
earlier you know when I wake up to go
for like a midnight piss or like a
midnight [__] when I just wake up uh
because I didn't go to the toilet
beforehand
um I have like a I have like a timer and
I know like it's it's weird because I
kind of get what you mean I consciously
know that there's a timer so when I take
a [__] um if I don't [__] fast enough
there's a timer for my brain to be like
okay you you are asleep enough to go
back to sleep too oh you're awake yeah
yeah you're awake now and you're not
getting back to sleep and uh you you
took too long to [__] the timer's run
now your [__] timer his run out your
[__] timer has run out brain awake you
do not go back to sleep and I'm like I
hate that because I can physically I can
physically feel my brain waking up I'm
like no no come on that's like one
that's like one thing I'm glad I got my
body got rid of is that like I just to
take midnight shifts every night well
you can you can kind of when I was in
high school but now I don't do it I'm
pretty sure you can somehow control your
bowel movements I don't know how
that is like teach me master I need to
know that [__] yeah I'm pretty sure
because like
I I poop at the exact same time near
enough every single day same and yeah I
don't know if that's good or bad but I
feel like I I know how to change it if I
want but I don't know how for me it's
not so much like the same time of day no
[__] sense yeah for me it's not so
much the same time of day for me it's
the same point of while I'm awake uh
yeah pretty much it's like for me it's
like no matter what time I wake up an
hour after I'm up I'm [__] yeah yeah
that's why I mean like 6 a.m it could be
[__] 1pm it's like always I I need my
morning [__] as much as I need my
morning shower that's like that's how
ingrained it is into my cycle that's why
I'm the only one that actually had to
stop the bus on tour to go [__] just
because it would like on that particular
day I could hold it I can hold it I
can't hold it man I woke up early I woke
up like I I say woke up early I think we
were just on on a very long drive and it
was like 9 A.M and I woke up and I'm
like oh no I've woken up and the bus is
still moving and then I I remember I
remember won't stop sticking down I
remember thinking because I think we
were driving through Utah and it was
like such a beautiful landscape and I I
woke up I go into like the living room
and like our tour family is just like oh
my God look at like look over Utah
mountains and Mike's next to me like yo
bro this is so [__] beautiful and I'm
like yeah it's uh beautiful and inside I
was like I feel it coming the shit's
coming just distract yourself just
distract yourself look at look at the
landscape and I remember everyone kept
commenting on the landscape and all I
could think about was how much I needed
to [__] in this very moment and how
close we were so yeah yeah that's a
great place to take a [__]
oh
literally I was like we're pretty
isolated right now I could uh I could
maybe I could like get away with this
you know maybe I could move in the
wilderness huh or [__] yourself no
going up to Lego [__] like what
you're gonna shoot yourself on the bus
and get away with it I could go over
like one of these mounds and no one I
don't want to see anything positions
sleep Stomach back side I cannot sleep
anything but on my back yeah oh well for
me it's either back or right side yeah
but so I I thought I was a side sleeper
but I realized I'm more of a like
third side two-thirds stomach I'm kind
of like this oh yeah kind of like side
but with my stomach leaning towards the
bed I cannot sleep on my back I do not
know why I'm unable to sleep on my back
I've tried many times and I cannot fall
asleep you're like I don't know I feel
like as and I want to learn I'm like do
you still sleep that wearing futons as
well uh yeah yeah okay okay always on my
sides and I didn't kind of use my arms
as like a like support because I feel
like the reason I sleep on my back was
just because as a kid uh you know every
time you go to Asia sometimes you don't
have a bed to sleep on you sleep on kind
of like a futon or some covers on the
floor and it's just impossible to do
that unless you're sleeping on your back
I feel like I kind of like that I like
my arms crumbled up feeling though I'm
squishing them against the floor right
it feels nice have you I have this thing
where I like develop what I call T-Rex
arms when I sleep where I'm just [__]
like this no I do that too yeah yeah
yeah I've seen that actually my favorite
my favorite Strat is the arm under the
pillow yeah but no one my head is just
like pillow here right in front right
yeah I love that feeling if they're just
a slight elevation I don't know why it's
so good I have that I feel like I'm in a
Sci-Fi movie when I sleep because I need
to be perfectly like straight like that
like I'm going to cry asleep I'm like
terrified if I [__] rob Grant's house
and I just see a man like
what was that [__] T100 yeah because
like sometimes if I sleep on my I've
tried to sleep on my side and I just
wake up because sometimes I just get
cramps I don't know yeah old man yeah if
I sleep on like in like a weird position
where it's like not on a normal side
maybe I'm so tired that I don't [__]
care what position I sleep in next
morning I am stiff like my my shoulders
are [__] aching and I'm like yeah
[__] all right what time I woke up as a
kid and my my head was like so I can
imagine I don't know how to explain it
like head in the on the bed and then my
like knees I was like on my knees though
so I was like oh I kind of like you're
like snailing kind of like a snail yeah
imagine a snail like that
like knees on the [__] bed and my
legs were kind of like up I guess yeah I
was like what the [__] do you have this
problem I because I constantly have this
problem with futons I wake up and the
pillow is nowhere near my head no I
don't have that do you have this no you
fighting the [__] pillow I don't
[__] know like I'm like I clearly
yeah I'm like when I sleep in a futon I
always have to sleep in my back because
you know there's less padding right
between you and the floor so I'm always
sleeping on my back head is perfectly on
the pillow like supporting my neck and
I'm like all right good I just have to
stay in this position yeah and I'm good
till the morning wake up the next
morning I'm somehow on my [__] side
like on the corner of the futon and I'm
like where did the pillow go and it's
like all the way up it's just on the
ceiling yeah yeah it's just like if the
futon is here the pillow is like down
here and I'm like how
no matter what state of mind you're in
do you always feel like you need like a
kind of like blanket or something
covering yeah yeah because uh yeah
that's something that's like remained
true no matter what even like even
during our degenerate days when we went
to like House parties and University of
course sometimes you get inebriated in
some stranger's house and I would always
need something yeah even if it's on the
floor I could sleep fine I'll find a
[__] pizza box which cover which has
no installation whatsoever but I've
woken up with a pizza box I've put over
myself do you remember one time when we
went
this is years ago uh but remember one
time when we also used to live near each
other yeah we went to like a house party
I think it was maylene's place and I was
so [__] late just shit-faced yeah
that you dragged me back to your house
and I woke up the next morning with two
pieces of cardboard
[__] and I'm just like lying on
Connor's couch like this with two pieces
of [__] like Amazon boxes I I didn't
have any because I literally just moved
in yeah yeah all I had was a couch and a
bunch of cardboard boxes starting to
part a bunch of cardboard boxes on top
of them to like help him I guess like
January yeah I remember this I had no
Heating and I was like I wake up the
next morning freezing with these like
two [__] boxes on me I'm like what
happened no because I remember I forgot
about that I I remember the night
because I remember taking him home with
you because I thought I was like sober I
clearly wasn't sober because I remember
I was we got Sydney up to the couch and
oh I remember asking Connor Connor do
you have do you have any spare blankets
and he just goes no and then we look
around and there are all of the
cardboard boxes that Connor has just
finished unpacking and we were just like
we can fashion a blanket out of this
this is fine this is fine why did you
stay in my house and why did I not take
you to yours I don't know why I don't
know they're all drunk I think I think
because because we took a taxi and it
was a small place yeah there's a little
bit of a walk from yours to mine yeah
you in your drunken state made the right
decision of I don't think he can make it
yeah yeah yeah just come yeah
yeah because I I remember thinking yeah
I don't know Joey's like actual address
yeah and my uh Japanese wasn't good
enough like direct the taxi driver yeah
beneath it so we're like let's just
let's just stay goddess I remember
walking out of that house being like
Joey's so drunk and then uh I'm a flight
I was like a 10 minute walk from Connor
cells like I remember walking like the
like Direction I thought was going to
home I walked for what I thought was
five minutes I'm like I remember just
looking up and being like
what the [__] am I I look at the I look
at the clock I've been walking for 30
minutes and Sydney's like I've Cindy's
like where the [__] are you I literally
had no idea where I was and somehow in
my drunken stupor I'd walk in half an
hour of the wrong direction from my
house if I'd realize I was lost so and I
was that was a good night yeah I got
myself got my got my goddamn steps in
well hopefully you don't have to sleep
with cardboard boxes tonight on you yeah
it's not it's not fun there was like
minus one that day it was a very cold
night I can say with uh certainties from
experience doesn't help with these
really there's no it's like it was like
point one percent it's like Placebo
thing but sometimes just having
something on top of you helps you I did
not work you're so confused it did not
work hey look at these patrons though
yeah look at all those patrons who get a
good night's sleep and sleep on their
sides
definitely pissed correctly
they don't piss in the dark yeah don't
do pistons piece of Faith it's not worth
it but hey you know what is worth it
supporting us on patreon by going to
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us memes on the
subreddit and if you hate her face
listen to us on Spotify oh but yes
that's been this episode of trash taste
hope you got some good pissing
techniques grooming techniques
but we'll see you all next week bye
[Music]